all right here's reaction all the
breaking news tonight delyth why we
fight just out this week defeating
America's enemies with no apologies Fox
News national security strategies
Sebastian Gorka also out this week
they're competing for the New York Times
top spot with Tucker Carlson the author
of Spygate the attempted sabotage at
Donald J Trump former Secret Service
agent NRA TV contributor Dan Mangino
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi who
herself was a victim of the mob and by
the way fake news CNN says you can't say
it's a mob you secretary Nielsen Sarah
Sanders Ted Cruz this is a mob that is
being incited by people like Maxine
Waters follow them into department
stores and restaurants if any
conservative did - a democratic woman
what was done to you Pam there would be
fire and fury to use a phrase there
certainly would Shawn and and it's the
classic definition of a mob if you look
up what a mob is in the dictionary its
inciting violence and that's what
they're doing
I was booed again the other night
someone saw me and yelled my name like
they had won the lottery basically the
lottery of being getting to be mean to a
human being and you know that's what the
world's turning into wives and they're
doing it to women the very people that
say that they have a monopoly a
compassion and that conservatives don't
exactly yeah
well I'm sorry you had to go through
that this is now what they're saying to
do we're seeing it daily and it is a mob
and Democrats are inciting this with
their words in many ways you know they
are Sean but I think this is happening
for a reason I think in this Trump era
we're now Trump just refuses to back
down to this political pressure through
the media the liberal swamp and these
activist groups it's enraged them Sean
the left for as much as I disagree with
them ideologically they're usually
tactically smarter than this but Trump
has them moving and scattered they just
don't know what to do anymore because
they're not used to a real political
fight Republicans would
elected Republicans would have back down
by now what the Trump refuses to do it
we're looking at Ted Cruz and and he's
with his wife Heidi and literally he has
to scored his wife and act as protection
doctor Gorka to get her out of the
restaurant because they can't even let
people sit for five seconds and our
piece think about the metric in America
today that you risk bodily harm if you
put on a red mega hat in many parts of
the United States that's actually an act
of courage the left walks around in
t-shirts with Che Guevara a mass
murderer on their chest we don't do
anything to them this is why the
midterms are crucial Sean do you want
the mob to run America do you want
people who will intimidate you if you do
not toe their line that's what the next
twenty six days are about and Pam when
when Kanye said today that it's freeing
and it really is a sign of courage I'm
not gonna let anybody tell me how to
think and I'm gonna wear my make America
great again hat well you could have
pulled back a little bit on the cursing
in the Oval Office but we'll put that
aside for a second most people have
cursed in their lives but you know it's
sad that we have the best the lowest
unemployment for african-americans
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans and
somebody saying good job let's do more
of this and Kanye's a businessman Sean
and he's a capitalist and he understands
that and he's saying let's make more
products in the United States he gets it
and he knows all the good that the
president has done for the country and
Kanye West is brave he's his own man
he's not scared to speak his mind and
we're his make America great again hat
and none of us are gonna be victims
frankly Ted Cruz was out there
protecting his wife and you know
everyone's gonna continue to do what's
right despite what the former chief
legal officer of our entire country said
to kick people when they're down it's
despicable and I know everything what
he's saying anyway I don't I'm sure I
don't agree on
everything I disagree with a lot stoppin
first cuz it worked in New York and
lives were saved but damn bond Gina
I agree on prison reform I agree on
safer cities and I agree make products
in America and create more jobs for
Americans I'm all-in yeah Shawn I've
been really vocal about this I wish a
lot of the establishment type
Republicans who are selling this moment
short would take a timeout and think
about this wherever we fell short over
the years cultural capital Democrats
have built up a bank account of cultural
capital through Hollywood and
celebrities and finally we have people
with cultural capital saying hey these
Republicans aren't crazy let's see what
they have to say it's a big deal
dr. korkor by the way you clean up
really well your show Shawn will give
you what gives you the last word look
it's very very simple
they have no policies they have no
argument all they have is intimidation
and we will not let them get away with
it all right thank you all thanks for
taking a break from that event Pam we're
sorry what you went through